first off soak the noodles these are
thin glass noodles basically bring the
kettle of the boil and just pour just
let them steep there for a couple
minutes
the noodles are for my porn roles as
they soak I'm gonna make a spicy dipping
sauce to go with them start off with
sugar we're trying to create that sweet
sour salty but a real nice sort of
heated sauce as well rice wine vinegar
that will dissolve a sugar fish sauce
now that's gonna give it its saltiness
next the chili I want the seeds left in
cuz I want some power chili in a little
bit of garlic don't need to chop it too
finely just slice it take a spring onion
just top and tell them slice slice is
bringing a nice and thinly so it's sort
of almost permeates that dipping sauce I
grew up with the love of spring rolls
but on the back of my visit to Vietnam
it sort of transformed my respect for a
spring roll give that a little mix a
little bit of coriander and fresh mint
roll them up and chopped herbs in
there's no olive oil in there no cream
there's no butter so it's a really nice
light dipping sauce and Wow
all those sensors going on now will make
the filling for the wraps a really nice
fresh noodle salad rinse the noodles in
cold water then chop them into
bite-sized lengths
prawns peeled and coat slice them up the
prawns give a really nice sweetness next
the vegetables I want crunch freshness
texture baby gem lettuce
I just shred that lettuce next spring
onion the good news about these wraps is
that you can make them up in advance sit
them in the fridge and then take them
out literally seconds before you guess
arrive till the care so you got a really
nice fresh crunchy carrot now fresh mint
fresh basil and fresh coriander together
it sounds a little bit bizarre but
tastes amazing don't hold back with the
herbs they'll really help make the
filling vibrant fresh and aromatic
finally touch a lime to squeeze that
fresh lime juice over there a couple of
tablespoons of your dipping sauce don't
put too much in there just makes all the
filling too wet just give that a really
good mix that's a very quick simple
salad to eat now but let's get it into a
wrap now take your rice paper wrap
literally 30 seconds in warm water you
can get rice paper wraps from your local
Asian supermarket or buy them online
shénme lift out the water ah beautiful
lay it carefully onto your board place
the mixture at the bottom don't overfill
it because it'd be a nightmare to raw
fold them over first nice and tightly
halfway and tuck in the ends make sure
nothing's coming out the sides neutral
it's a light fragrant incredibly simple
to do and there you go a very delicious
fragrant Asian wrap sunny different to
the Chinese spring rolls I grew up with
next have capers fresh dill and slices
of lemon ice and firmly look at your lie
where the string was and look this one
is gonna be amazing